ourselves of course we are educated we
are able to
uh inspire our learners in my case
uh if let's say i want to encourage
people to design buildings better it's
not just a question of
showing them the principles but we have
to actually construct a building
and ask them to come inside it feel how
it is then they be more interested and
say yes this works and then
we can try it on their own yeah we could
take it a step further
really to say okay if we are introducing
clarity
what are the other options because
people then need options
if i look at some the history of
texas africa in zambia in particular
we had people that already are using uh
tree fibers to to to make uh
close i think this is uh one topic which
like
is common for both of us because i work
in the field of construction industry of
course
but we do we use natural fibers a lot so
pineapple fibers
banana fibers and coconut i think that
um
to dominate if not or to be
you know very very powerful in in the
future actually i have i have quite high
hopes from the
from the young generation because i
think they are environmental
away now when we talk of these things to
them it seems to want to do things
but it's not always possible for them to
know what to do
you